lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
demostrar la famosa útil y hasta cierto
punto elegante regla de la cadena muy
bien eso es lo que vamos a demostrar en
este vídeo la regla de la cadena muy
bien y si ha seguido los vídeos donde
vimos que la deriva bilidad implica la
continuidad y también el vídeo donde
vimos que qué es lo que le pasaba a una
función continua si el cambio en x
tendía a cero donde x será la variable
independiente si has visto esos dos
vídeos entonces la prueba de la regla de
la cadena resulta ser muy fácil y
directa la regla de la cadena nos dice
lo siguiente que si nosotros tenemos una
composición de funciones digamos que
tenemos una función y que está evaluada
en x donde ud x es otra función y
nosotros queremos derivar esta expresión
verdad si nosotros queremos derivar esta
expresión por supuesto
más que esta es la derivada de jake con
respecto de x esto se traduce en un
cálculo algebraico muy sencillo esto es
la derivada de y con respecto de v por
la derivada de v con respecto de x así
que para poder realizar todos estos
cálculos primero tenemos que hacer
algunas suposiciones verdad vamos a
suponer nosotros vamos a suponer que
tanto la función como la función y son
derivables son derivables en el punto x
muy bien entonces a partir de esta
suposición vamos a poder demostrar la
regla de la cadena entonces vamos a ver
quién es la derivada de jake con
respecto de x muy bien entonces esto por
la definición que nosotros tenemos de
derivada es el límite cuando el cambio
en x tiende a cero del cambio en g
sobre el cambio en x verdad éste
simplemente la define
de la derivada y aquí es en donde vamos
a utilizar una manipulación algebraica
para poder llegar al resultado que
nosotros queremos así que esto será el
límite cuando delta x o el camión x
tiende a cero y quizás valdría la pena
hacer un código de colores aquí entonces
esto de aquí lo vamos a reescribir y
vamos a dividir entre el cambio en y
multiplicar por el cambio no entonces no
tenemos el cambio de verdad dividido
entre el cambio en y y ahora
multiplicamos por el cambio no teníamos
dividiendo el cambio en x entonces si te
das cuenta en realidad estos dos números
se cancelan y tenemos exactamente lo que
teníamos anteriormente pero esta nueva
expresión que obtuvimos simplemente de
multiplicar y dividir por delta
nos ayuda porque ahora el límite lo
podemos separar como un producto de
límites verdad esto será igual
esto será igual al límite cuando delta x
tiende a cero verdad de la primera
expresión digamos esta sería del taller
entre delta y por ahora multiplicamos
por el límite límite cuando delta x
tiende a cero de nuestra segunda de
nuestro segundo producto verdad que es
perdón por el segundo factor que es
delta y entre delta x lo único que
hicimos aquí fue separar el límite de un
producto en el producto de los límites
muy bien y entonces si nos fijamos en
este segundo factor tenemos el límite
cuando delta x tiende a cero de delta o
entre delta equis entonces esto es
justamente la de la definición de la
derivada de eeuu en el punto xy es
existe porque supusimos que era
en x verdad entonces esto simplemente lo
podemos ver como la derivada de v con
respecto de x y algo similar vamos a
utilizar en este ejemplo anterior verdad
o más bien debería decir en este factor
anterior ya que bueno esto se parece
mucho a la derivada de y con respecto de
v pero aquí te debería aparecer el delta
tendiendo a cero entonces hay que notar
dos cosas la primera de ellas es que
como ves derivable en x entonces podemos
garantizar que es continua verdad eso lo
vimos en hacer no sé tal vez dos vídeos
ahora si es continua que es lo que le
pasa al cambio en o cuando el cambio de
x tiende a cero y eso lo teníamos en el
vídeo anterior verdad cuando delta x
tiende a cero el cambio en uno tiende a
cero muy bien entonces esto que tenemos
aquí podríamos simplemente sustituirlo
por el cambio
tendiendo a cero y entonces si esta es
exactamente la definición de la derivada
de y con respecto de un muy bien y
entonces ahí tenemos un el resultado que
queríamos verdad así de fácil si tenemos
que la función y la función y son
derivables en x verdad y por supuesto la
función y es en realidad una función de
eeuu que es función de x que parece
trabalenguas entonces tan sólo usando
resultados muy sencillos de deriva
habilidad y de continuidad concluimos
que la derivada de con respecto de x es
igual a la derivada de ya con respecto
de eeuu por la derivada de eeuu con
respecto de x